Hace tres años viajé a la República Centroafricana
para informar sobre la guerra en curso.
Había oído advertencias de genocidios
en las selvas y desiertos del país,
pero nadie podía saber donde ocurrían estos genocidios
o decirme a quién habían asesinado o cuándo.
Irrumpí en la guerra
con poca información.
Presencié escenas trágicas e irreales,
y al final, pude darme cuenta
que fui testigo del minucioso plan de limpieza étnica.
La República Centroafricana es un país de alrededor de 5 millones de personas,
tan enorme como Texas,
en el centro de África.
El país sufría de grave violencia desde la caída de la colonia francesa en 1960.
La guerra de la que yo informé
era entre el gobierno minoritario musulmán,
llamados los Seleka,
y las milicias civiles,
en su mayoría cristiana,
llamada los anti-balaka.
La primera señal de limpieza inminente
era la crisis de confianza dentro de las comunidades.
Tres días después de mi llegada al país,
Vi que la pequeña ciudad estaba abandonada.
Una guerra iba a estallar.
Para poder salvarse,
muchos se convirtieron en espías del gobierno,
entregando a amigos y vecinos
para matarlos.
Las ciudades y aldeas,
cualquier lugar donde hubiera humanos era ya inseguro.
Así que, la gente se mudó a la selva.
Me sentí muy aislado
cuando los cerdos y el ganado entraban a las casas vacías.
En una zona de guerra,
sabes que estás cerca de la muerte cuando la gente ya no está.
La guerra se movía hacia la selva llegando hasta Gaga.
El estruendo de bombas me rodeaba.
El gobierno fue a la selva para atacar a las milicias escondidas en la ciudad.
Conduje una moto por horas,
atravesando la selva y el alto pasto elefante.
Sin embargo, cuando llegué a la aldea,
el gobierno ya la había incendiado
y su gente había huido.
Para ver si había alguien,
tuve que gritar que era un amigo y que no lastimaría a nadie.
Una mujer con camiseta roja salió corriendo del bosque.
Otros salieron precavidamente de los árboles
y preguntaron: "Est-ce que les gens savent?"
¿La gente sabe?
La pregunta me sorprendió.
Sus hijos tenían hambre y estaban enfermos,
pero no pidieron alimentos ni medicamentos.
Me preguntaron:
¿La gente sabe lo que nos ocurre?
Me sentí impotente al anotar su pregunta.
Y decidí entonces
que este momento en sus vidas
debería recordarse.
Al relatar su desgracia,
sentí cierta conexión con esta gente.
Desde lejos, muchas noticias del mundo no dejaban de hablar de esta guerra.
Como testigo,
la guerra era como desarrollar una historia.
El gobierno negó haber cometido algún acto de violencia.
No obstante, yo seguido iba a las aldeas
donde la gente describía los genocidios del gobierno
de un día o semana antes.
Me sentía agobiado
e intentaba calmarme.
Cuando informé de estas matanzas,
compraba y comía
golosinas,
procurando que fueran de su agrado.
los centroafricanos comían estos dulces
para mitigar el hambre,
dejando rastro de las miles de envolturas de plástico mientras huían.
En algunas de las estaciones de radio que seguían operando en el país,
escuchaba casi siempre música pop.
A medida que la guerra avanzaba,
recibíamos menos información de los asesinatos.
Fue más fácil sentirse normal ante esto.
Presencié los efectos de la falta de información.
Dos semanas más tarde, ingresé,
lenta y nerviosamente, a un cuartel general abandonado,
a una aldea llamada PK100.
En este lugar, los luchadores cristianos me contaron
que todos los musulmanes eran extranjeros,
malvados y que estaban aliados con el gobierno.
Comparaban a los musulmanes con animales.
Por no haber observadores neutrales o medios informativos
que se opusieran a esta historia absurda,
esta fue la única correcta en los campos.
El ejército comenzó a capturar a los musulmanes,
y vació la capital, Bangui,
con un estimado de 140 000 musulmanes,
en solo pocos meses.
Los testigos no registraron la mayoría de los asesinatos y fugas musulmanes.
Les relato mi informe que hice en la República Centroafricana.
Sin embargo, aún me cuestiono el porqué estuve ahí.
¿Por qué exponerme?
Trabajo en esto
porque siento que la gente que es ignorada en nuestras comunidades
nos revela algo importante
sobre quiénes somos.
Cuando falta la información,
las personas pueden manipular la realidad.
Sin testigos,
seguiríamos creyendo que esas miles de personas asesinadas están vivas...
y que esos cientos de hogares quemados siguen ahí.
Una zona de guerra puede
considerarse un lugar pacífico
cuando nadie mira.
Y un testigo puede ser valioso,
y su mirada más que necesaria,
cuando la violencia es silenciosa,
inadvertida e inaudita.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)